le monde touche à sa fin
du mois c'est ce que les gens pensent
le ciel
[Musique]
tout est prêt monsieur le Président bien
voici le début d'une nouvelle ère
[Musique]
la planète lutte pour sa survie à
l'instant on nous parlons elle se défend
de toutes ses forces si l'énergie
spirituelle disparaît la planète meurt
et c'est la fin nous pouvons surmonter
le destin
des soldats contre été en héros
autrefois est-ce que tu peux retrouver
ses firos
très bien
tu as répondu à l'appel toi aussi
n'est-ce pas de quoi est-ce que tu
parles comme tu peux le voir tous tes
frères ont également fait le voyage pour
se rassembler
ces hommes en noir sont probablement à
sa poursuite
à mon avis ces hommes sont des soldats
qui ont subi une dégénérescence ne te
laisse pas avoir
tu le sais très bien je suis ton unique
vérité
[Musique]
avec moi
regardez ça
[Musique]
excuse-moi tu veux bien t'occuper de lui
je reviens tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une arme une des gardiennes elles
apparaissent pour défendre la planète
quand elle est menacée
au beau milieu d'un cauchemar qui
êtes-vous
réunion quand les mondes s'entremêlent
et qu'il fusionne
rejoint ma vie Cloud
[Musique]